قال رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني الى حكومته جاده في تطبيق
المعايير الصحيحه التي تضمن المحافظه على
المال العام وتمنع عمليات التهريب غسيل
الاموال والمضاربه في الاسواق واضاف
السوداني ان ارتفاع سعر صرف الدولار لم
يكن قرارا حكوميا انما اليه تم الاتفاق
عليها بين المؤسسات الماليه والبنك
المركزي وانه لا مبرر لرفع اسعار المواد
المستورده بعد توفر الدولار بالسعر الرسمي
هذا وقد اعفى رئيس الوزراء السوداني محافظ
المصرف المركزي مصطفى غالب مخيف من منصبه
وكلف علي محسن العلاقه باداره المصرف
بالوكاله كما حاله سوداني مدير المصرف
العراقي للتجاره الى التقاعد وكلف بلال
الحمداني باداره المصرف وكذا معظم النواب
قد تقدم وقدموا طلبا الى رئاسه البرلمان
لاستضافه محافظ البنك المركزي من اجل
الوقوف على اسباب ارتفاع الدولار ووضع
المعالجات اللازمه
اما لقاله وغير اللقاء قالت محافظ البنك
المركزي هذه ما راح يعيره لها اهميه
المواطن قدر ما يعير اهميه انه تكون هناك
نتيجه
بالسابق اشتري طبقه البيض ب 5000
اشري طبقه البيض ب5000 يعني
[موسيقى]
معنى من بغداد مرافق العربيه ماجد حميد
مجد يعني امام الاجراءات الصارمه التي
فرضها الفيدرا للامريكي لمنع تهريب
الدولار وتبييض الاموال من بغداد الى
العراق
عفوا من بغداد الى ايران والى سوريا ويعني
الملاذ الضريبه هناك امام هذه النقطه
وامام موضوع يعني ما يشع داخل العراق
اليوم عن الضغط الامريكي لي الضغط على
حكومه السوداني وامام يعني الفساد الموجود
كل هذه الصوره كيف هي من هناك
نعم عمليا الجانب الامريكي كان قد اتخذ
عده اجراءات خلال الشهرين الماضيه ان تمثل
بعمليه عقوبات على عدد من المصارف
العراقيه الاهليه ومنع عمليه بيع الدولار
لوجود فواتير مزوره تم اكتشافها من خلال
عمليه بيع العمله الى المصارف الاهليه بما
يعرف بمزاد العمله في البنك المركزي
العراقي هناك نقطه مهمه في التقرير الاخير
الذي صدر من قبل هيئه النزاهه العراقيه
اشاره تقرير بان اكبر عمليه فساد بتاريخ
العراقيه متمثله في مزاد العمله ومن خلال
يتم بيع الدولار للمصارف الاهليه بعض هذه
المصاره في الاهليه وبحسب معلوماتيه
مملوكه او تقوم بعمليه تهريب الدولار
باتجاه سوريا وكذلك ايران وبعض الوجوه هي
مرتبطه اصلا بايران تم فرض عقوبات عليها
من قبل الجانب الامريكي القرارات التي
اتخذت متعاقبه في ظل حكومه السيد الكاظم
وصولا الى محمد اشياء السوداني تمتلت
بنقطتين النقطه الاولى انه اي بضاعه تدخل
من خلال جمارك اي الحدود يجب ان تكون هناك
فواتير الكترونيه مصدقه من قبل السفارات
العراقيه الموجوده في هذه البلدان ومن ثم
ترسل الى البنك المركزي عمليا بدات بدا
الجانب الامريكي بعمليه تدقيق اكبر على
الدولار الخارج باتجاه من داخل العراق الى
خارج العراق لذلك تم تقليل عمليه الدفع من
الدولار من الجانب الامريكي باتجاه العراق
مما ادى لعمليه الارتفاع الشارع العراقي
لا يلومون الجانب الامريكي هو يلوم الجهات
الحكوميه التي لم تسيطر على عمليه التهريب
تهريب الدولار والعمله الصعبه الى ايران
وكذلك الى سوريا لذلك هناك عده خطوات
اتخذت من يوم امس من قبل رئيس الوزراء
محمد الشيعه السوداني تمثلت في عمليه فتح
نوافذ جديده لعمليه بيع العمله هناك نقطه
في مصر في المصارف العراقيه الاهليه
والبنك المركزي وكذلك المصاري في الحكوميه
عمليا يتم بيع الدولار ب 147 الف دينار
لكل مئه دولار لذلك عمليه
التي تجري في الاسواق عمليه المضاربه التي
تجري بين بعض البنوك الاهليه هي التي دفعت
بعمليه ارتفاع الدولار وصل يوم امس الى
166,000 اليوم تراجع وانا اتحدث معك الى
الخمسينات نحن نتحدث عن 155,000 بعد قرار
السودان بعزل همم محافظ البنك المركزي
وكذلك محافظ
وكذلك مدير احد المصارف الحكوميه العراقيه
لذلك ننتظر الى يوم غد ونرى هل سيكون هناك
على هذه الصعود جديد ام لا سيتم عمليه
التراجع تدريجيا للوصول الى السحر الرسمي
147,000 دينار لكل 100$ خاصه بان هناك
اجتماع عقد قبل قليل من الان تراسه محمد
همم تميم وهو وزير التخطيط العراقي مع
وزيره الماليه وفؤاد حسين الذي سيتراس
الوفد العراقي الى واشنطن مطلع الشهر
القادم لمناقشه ملف الدولار وملفات اخرى
شكرا لك مراسل العربيه